This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. One of the cool parts about moving to a new city or a new state or a new country is that you notice all these fascinating things about a place that are just normal for people who have been there a long time. When Chris Carlier moved from England to Japan in 2002, there was one thing that really stood out to him. I think a lot of Japanese people go about that day and they don't really pay any attention to the mascots that are everywhere. The mascots.
这里是99% Invisible，我是罗马·马斯。搬到一个新城市、新州或新国家最酷的事情之一，就是你会注意到这个地方所有那些迷人的事物，而对长期生活在那里的人来说，这些都只是司空见惯的日常。2002年，当克里斯·卡利尔从英国搬到日本时，有一件事深深吸引了他。我想很多日本人过着日常生活时，并不会真正去注意那些随处可见的吉祥物。吉祥物。
Real-world, life-size character costumes with sweaty actors inside. Most people ignore them, but I always found them really fascinating. Here in the US, mascots are used to pump up crowds at sporting events or traumatized generations of children at Chuck E. Cheese. But in Japan, it's different. There are mascots for towns, aquariums, prisons. Sometimes I just go to the dentist
现实生活中真人大小的角色戏服，里面装着汗流浃背的演员。大多数人对它们视而不见，但我一直觉得它们非常迷人。在美国，吉祥物被用来在体育赛事中炒热气氛，或者在查克E切酪（Chuck E. Cheese）里给几代儿童留下童年阴影。但在日本，情况有所不同。城镇、水族馆、监狱都有吉祥物。有时候我只是去牙医诊所，
and the dentist has their own mascot. There are mascots that tell people not to litter or remind them to stay quiet on the train. Everything has a mascot and anything can be a mascot. There are mascots that tell people not to litter, or remind them to stay quiet on the train. Everything has a mascot and anything can be a mascot. There's an anthropomorphized bare mascot. There's an anthropomorphized melon mascot. There's an anthropomorphized bear whose head is made out of a melon.
然后牙医诊所也有他们自己的吉祥物。有些吉祥物会告诉人们不要乱扔垃圾，或者提醒大家在火车上保持安静。万物皆有吉祥物，万物皆可成为吉祥物。有些吉祥物会告诉人们不要乱扔垃圾，或者提醒大家在火车上保持安静。万物皆有吉祥物，万物皆可成为吉祥物。有一个拟人化的熊吉祥物。有一个拟人化的甜瓜吉祥物。还有一个拟人化的熊，它的脑袋是一个甜瓜做成的。
His name is Melon Kuma, and he's the mascot of a region known for both its bears and its melons. And so, as Carlier adjusted to his new life in Tokyo, he started snapping photos of all these mascots. He was coming across. Yeah, I just realized one day I had hundreds of pictures of mascots, so I started putting them online. Carlier's hobby has since morphed into a wildly popular Twitter account called Mondo mascots, and if you were to build a Twitter account in a lab, you could not concoct a more Vivian-lay set of content than this Twitter account. Yeah, it's one of my favorite things on the internet. That's producer Vivian-lay.
他的名字叫Melon Kuma（哈密瓜熊），是一个以盛产熊和甜瓜而闻名的地区的吉祥物。因此，随着卡利尔逐渐适应他在东京的新生活，他开始拍摄他偶遇的所有这些吉祥物的照片。是的，我有一天突然意识到自己有几百张吉祥物的照片，于是我开始把它们发到网上。卡利尔的这个爱好后来演变成了一个名为Mondo Mascots的、极受欢迎的推特账号，如果你要在实验室里打造一个推特账号，你绝对设计不出比这个推特账号更符合薇薇安·李（Vivian Le）风格的内容了。是的，这是我互联网上最喜欢的东西之一。那是制作人薇薇安·李。
Twitter has been a rollercoaster ride of emotions for the past few months, so it's a real treat to see a picture of a manatee with a pompadour made out of cabbage. Usually these costume mascots are out interacting with the world, waving at tourists and opening supermarkets, but like the rest of us, they recently had to spend a lot of time indoors in order to flatten the curve of the coronavirus. One mascot was making quarantine workout videos for people's stig at home. Another posted photo after photo of himself just staring blankly into space. But around mid-march, I saw something kind of odd and very meta happening on the Mondo mascots twitter.
过去几个月里，推特就像是一场情绪的过山车，所以看到一张头顶由卷心菜做成的庞巴度发型的海牛照片，实在是一种享受。通常这些布偶吉祥物都在外面与世界互动，向游客挥手并为超市开业剪彩，但就像我们其他人一样，它们最近不得不花很多时间待在室内，以便拉平冠状病毒的感染曲线。有一个吉祥物一直在为宅家的人们制作隔离健身视频。另一个则接连发布了多张自己呆呆望着虚空的自拍照。但大约在3月中旬，我在Mondo Mascots的推特上看到了一些有点奇怪且非常“套娃”的事情。
Some of the more well-known mascots were adding these similar new flourishes on top of the regular mascot costumes. They were all wearing long flowing blue wigs and colorful fish scales. The mascots were dressing up as the same creature. I posted some mascots dressed as a kind of mermaid type creature with long hair and three legs It was a mythical character called Amabye, a 174-year-old monster that has recently become the unexpected hero of the COVID era in Japan. What's going on in this tweet here is that local mascots are now dressing up as Amabye as a form of cosplay, a form of meta-cost play.
一些较为知名的吉祥物正在常规的吉祥物服装上添加这些类似的全新装饰。它们都戴着长长的流苏蓝假发和五颜六色的鱼鳞。吉祥物们打扮成了同一种生物。我发布了一些吉祥物，它们打扮成了一种长发三条腿的美人鱼类生物。这是一个名为Amabie（アマビエ，阿玛比埃）的神话角色，一个174岁的怪物，最近意外成为了日本新冠时代的英雄。这条推特里发生的事情是，当地的吉祥物现在为了进行某种Cosplay（角色扮演）、一种套娃式的角色扮演而打扮成了阿玛比埃。
That's Matt Alt, a writer and translator based in Tokyo. Because there's obviously somebody in these costumes who's dressed up as the regional mascot who is now dressing up as a mobier. Does that make sense? No, not really. There's so many layers. It's like an onion.
那是马特·阿尔特（Matt Alt），一位居住在东京的作家兼翻译家。因为这些服装里显然有人穿着区域吉祥物的衣服，而这个吉祥物现在又打扮成了一个阿玛比埃。这说得通吗？不，其实说不通。这里面有太多的层级了。就像洋葱一样。
Just peel the layers back. Matt wrote about a Mabye for the New Yorker and is also the co-author of a book called Yo-Kai Attack, the Japanese Monster Survival Guide. I spoke with both him and his co-author, Heroku Yoda, in order to peel back all of the oniony history layers of this Twitter moment. Matt and Heroku explained to me that a Mabye
只要把层层剥开就行了。马特为《纽约客》撰写过关于阿玛比埃的文章，他也是一本书的合著者，书名为《妖怪袭击：日本怪物生存指南》（Yokai Attack! The Japanese Monster Survival Guide）。我采访了他和他的合著者芳库·约达（Hiroko Yoda），以便剥开这个推特热潮背后层层叠叠的洋葱般的历史。马特和芳库向我解释说，阿玛比埃
is a creature from Japanese folklore, what's called a yokai. Yokai are monsters from Japanese folklore, and they've been part of the oral storytelling tradition here in Japan since before Japan has been Japan, and they are basically superstitions with personalities. Yeah, the yokai are characterization of natural phenomena or unexplained phenomena. other stitions with personalities. Yokai is a pretty broad term that includes everything from shape-shifting demons to cuddly animal-like creatures to spirited inanimate objects.
是日本民间传说中的一种生物，也就是所谓的“妖怪”。妖怪是日本民间传说中的怪物，自日本成为日本之前起，它们就一直是日本口头讲故事传统的一部分，它们基本上就是带有个性的迷信。是的，妖怪是对自然现象或无法解释现象的人格化。带有个性的迷信。妖怪是一个相当广泛的术语，包括从变形的恶魔到可爱的动物般生物，再到有灵气的无生命物体。
And it also ghosts. It's kind of like trying to lump fairies, vampires, leprechauns, and angry toaster into the same category. Yokai are supernatural manifestations of the unknown. If you don't know what made that noise that went bump in the night, you blame it on Yokai. Occasionally, they take the form of benevolent guardian angels, while some Yokai are completely innocuous. One of my favorites is the azuki arai, which is a spirit that washes azuki beans, and that's it. But more often than not, they're malevolent beans associated with a specific place,
还有幽灵。这有点像是试图把仙女、吸血鬼、小妖精和生气的烤面包机归入同一类别。妖怪是未知的超自然表现形式。如果你不知道是什么声音在夜里发出了砰砰的撞击声，你就会把它归咎于妖怪。有时，它们会化身为慈悲的守护天使，而有些妖怪则完全无害。我最喜欢的一个是Azuki Arai（小豆洗），这是一个洗小豆的精灵，仅此而已。但更多时候，它们是与特定地点相关的恶意精灵，
kind of like regional ghosts or the troll that lives under a particular bridge. If you go to this part of the river, you might be pulled underwater by a kappa, a river goblin. If you go to this part of the mountains, you might be spirited away by a tangu, which is like a big, a raven-like creature. The first yokai stories were told in the 8th century, but you can see the traces of yokai that stem thousands of years back to Japan's native religion called shintoism. The shintoism teaches you basically appreciate things surrounding you. And the things surrounding you
有点像地方幽灵或住在特定桥下的巨魔。如果你去河流的这个部分，你可能会被河童——一种河中妖怪——拖入水底。如果你去山里的这个部分，你可能会被天狗——一种大大的、长得像乌鸦的生物——神隐。最早的妖怪故事讲于8世纪，但你可以看到妖怪的痕迹可以追溯到几千年前日本本土的宗教——神道教。神道教教导你基本上要感激周围的事物。而你周围的事物
shouldn't just be appreciated, but respected. For shinto, we believe in the nature like a forest, mountain, it has a spirit. So we respect the nature of spirits. This is Izumi Hasegawa head priest at Shinto Shrine of Shusei and Rai in America. Hasegawa says that Shinto was a religion that's so tightly woven into the fabric of Japanese society that it's difficult to separate where the religion ends and Japanese culture begins. More than they Japanese people didn't realize Shinto is our college's basis.
不仅应该被感激，还应该被尊重。对于神道教来说，我们相信自然就像森林、山脉一样，它是有灵魂的。所以我们尊重自然的灵魂。这是泉长谷川（Izumi Hasegawa），美国修sei和rai神道神社的主持神职人员。长谷川说，神道教是一种紧密编织进日本社会结构中的宗教，以至于很难分清宗教在哪里结束，日本文化又在哪里开始。比起意识到这一点，日本人并没有意识到神道教是我们文化的基础。
So I say it's not revision, it's more like a way of living in the college tradition custom. Hasegawa says that Shintoism is a belief system that venerates millions of deities that live all around us and impact daily life. After the rain stopped and sun shined and the plants grow so well, maybe like a sun has some kind of spirits. Rain, water has some kind of spirit. The growing, the productivity has some kind of the spirits. We should respect them.
所以我说这不是宗教，它更像是一种生活在文化传统习俗中的方式。长谷川说，神道教是一个崇拜数百万存在于我们周围并影响日常生活的神灵的信仰体系。雨停了，太阳照耀，植物长得很好，也许太阳有某种灵魂。雨水、水有某种灵魂。生长、生产力有某种灵魂。我们应该尊重它们。
These chinto spirits are called kami and they reside within everything, from the trees to the wind, even your iPhone. Shintoism fosters the mindset that everything in the world is animated and has a spirit. Anything can become a character. Everything is alive. You have this belief system in which nearly anything can be receptacle for a deity or a soul, and many of those coming are actually personifications, that worldview, that belief system of polytheism and animism, is the soil from which Yokai emerged? In the beginning tales of spirit monsters varied drastically from region to region, and were
这些神道教的灵魂被称为“神”（kami），它们存在于万物之中，从树木到风，甚至你的iPhone。神道教培养了一种心态，即世间万物都是有生命的并且都有灵魂。任何事物都可以成为一个角色。万事万物都是活的。你有这样一种信仰体系：几乎任何东西都可以成为神灵或灵魂的容器，而许多神其实是人格化的，这种世界观、多神论和万物有灵论的信仰体系，就是妖怪孕育生长的土壤？在最初的时候，精灵怪物的故事因地区而异，并且作为
passed on as verbal stories with no real visual form attached. A copper water goblin from the south might be described totally differently from a copper from the north. That is, until the Edo period. The Edo period, which took place between 1603 and 1868, was a time of political stability and economic growth for Japan. And during this time, the publishing industry
口头故事流传开来，没有附加真正的视觉形式。来自南方的河童水怪可能与来自北方的河童的描述完全不同。直到江户时代。江户时代发生在1603年至1868年之间，对日本来说是一个政治稳定和经济增长的时期。在这个时期，出版业
really started taking off. In the 17th, 18th, and 19th centuries in Japan, one of the most popular forms of book was the Encyclopedia. And Encyclopædias are, what, full of data and information. Well, around 1776, a artist named Toriyama Sekian came around and he published a parody encyclopedia that wasn't full of facts at all. It was an encyclopedia of Yokai. Second created a catalog that gave each Yokai a name, a description, and an illustrated image associated with it.
真正开始腾飞。在17、18和19世纪的日本，最受欢迎的书籍形式之一是百科全书。而百科全书里装满了什么？数据和信息。嗯，大约在1776年，一位名叫鸟山石燕（Toriyama Sekian）的艺术家出现并出版了一本戏仿百科全书，它根本不装满事实。这是一部妖怪百科全书。石燕创建了一个目录，给每个妖怪起了一个名字、描述，并附带了与之相关的插图。
And this was the moment that the modern concept of Yokai emerged. Second's books were some of the first mass-produced reference images of Yokai. The entire nation was literally on the same page about who these monsters were and what they looked like. Before the Toyama Sikian's book came out, the Yokai were only drawn on Japanese scrolls,
这就是妖怪的现代概念涌现的时刻。石燕的书是最早批量生产的妖怪参考图像之一。整个国家对这些怪物是谁以及它们长什么样，字面上达到了共识。在鸟山石燕的书问世之前，妖怪只被画在日本的卷轴上，
but the people in general cannot really see them. It essentially cemented the image of a lot of Yokai in place, and those are the images that we know today. By creating an illustrated index of them, Sekian took all these local legends and consolidated them in place, and those are the images that we know today. and as a way of explaining the many unknowns of the world, including explaining highly infectious diseases caused by invisible microorganisms. You know, today we have science to explain. Like plague, for example, but back in time, there's not much information about medical, and so it's very unknown.
但普通人其实看不到它们。它基本上巩固了许多妖怪的形象，而这些正是我们今天所知道的形象。通过创建它们的插图索引，石燕将所有这些地方传说整合并在原地固定下来，而这些正是我们今天所知道的形象。作为解释世界上许多未知事物的一种方式，包括解释由看不见的微生物引起的高度传染性疾病。你知道，今天我们有科学来解释。比如瘟疫，但在过去，医学信息不多，所以非常未知。
And that's when the yoga comes to play. about medical, and so it's very unknown. And that's when the yoga comes to play. And the plague was actually where the Yokai known as a Mabyei specifically came into play. Throughout the 19th century, cholera epidemics were sweeping the world, and Japan was hit especially hard. Wave after wave of outbreaks devastated the country
这就是妖怪登场的时候。关于医学的，所以非常未知。这就是妖怪登场的时候。而瘟疫实际上正是被称为阿玛比埃的妖怪具体登场的地方。在整个19世纪，霍乱疫情席卷全球，日本受到的打击尤其严重。一波又一波的疫情在几十年间
over the course of several decades. And at the same time, very little was known about the disease and how to fight it. According to an actual newspaper story at the time, a Mobi egg was spotted off the coast of southwestern Japan in 1846. For several nights in a row, villagers could see a mysterious light radiating off the coast towards the sea. One night, an officer was sent to investigate the source. He followed the light towards the water until he was greeted by a strange-looking creature who appeared out of the sea.
摧毁了这个国家。与此同时，人们对这种疾病以及如何与之对抗知之甚少。根据当时的一则真实报纸报道，1846年，在日本西南部海岸发现了一只阿玛比埃。连续好几个夜晚，村民们都能看到一道神秘的光芒从海岸照向大海。一天晚上，一名官员被派去调查光源。他顺着光芒走向水边，直到一个从海里出现的奇怪生物向他打招呼。
It had the beak of a bird, long locks of human-like hair, a body covered in scales, and three legs with web feet, kind of like cross between mermaid and a duck. And it declared that its name was Amabie. It said that there would be a abundant harvest. And then it said, If plague should ever ravage these lands again, show an image of me to the people, and then it was gone. It appeared in a Japanese newspaper of the era as a little article, and it was accompanied by a very charmingly crude drawing that looks almost like a child
它有着鸟的喙、长长的人类般的头发、覆盖着鳞片的身体，以及长着蹼的三条腿，有点像是美人鱼和鸭子的结合体。它宣称它的名字叫阿玛比埃。它说将会有一个丰收的年景。然后它说，如果瘟疫再次蹂躏这些土地，请把我的形象展示给人们看，然后它就消失了。它作为一小篇文章出现在那个时代的日本报纸上，并配有一幅非常迷人、粗糙的画，看起来几乎像是一个孩子
might have done it. Because of that story, Amabye became a talisman against plague in Japan. People would draw a picture of it and display it for others to see so that Amabye would protect the world from harm. Mythical creatures like a Mabye played an important societal role within Japan in the 1800s. But by the turn of the 20th century, Japan's relationship with its Yokai began to shift.
可能画出来的样子。因为这个故事，阿玛比埃在日本成为了抗击瘟疫的护身符。人们会画一幅它的画并展示出来供大家观看，这样阿玛比埃就会保护世界免受伤害。像阿玛比埃这样的神话生物在19世纪的日本社会中发挥了重要的作用。但到了20世纪之交，日本与其妖怪的关系开始发生转变。
Largely because of one man in particular, a philosopher named Inoue Enrio. So Inoue Engo is known as Dr. Yokai. If you see that word, Dr. Yokai, it sounds like he is reading into Yokai. But it was the exact opposite. He made it his mission to displace Yokai from the Japanese psyche for good. Inoue was born right at the beginning of the Meiji Restoration,
主要是因为一个人，一个名叫井上圆了（Inoue Enryo）的哲学家。所以井上圆了被称为“妖怪博士”。如果你看到“妖怪博士”这个词，听起来他是在深入研究妖怪。但事实却恰恰相反。他的使命是将妖怪从日本人的心理中彻底根除。井上出生在明治维新刚开始的时候，
which was a moment when Japan began opening up to the rest of the world after hundreds of years of isolation. But as the country began opening up, leaders wanted to be able to compete with Western countries in terms of science, technology, and military power. So in his eyes and in the sound politicians to Japan, it's very behind from the West, and military power.
那是日本在经历了数百年的孤立之后开始向世界其余部分开放的时刻。但随着国家开始开放，领导层希望能够在科学、技术和军事力量方面与西方国家竞争。所以在他的眼中以及当时日本政客的眼中，日本远远落后于西方，在军事力量上也是如此。
He no way saw Yokai as a crutch holding back the nation. If Japan was going to become a world power, it needed to actively embrace modern science and technology. He felt that so long as people clung to Yokai in superstition to explain the way they are known, Japan would never reach its full potential. He went around the country finding examples of superstitions or places where people said a spirit was responsible for things or urban legends and basically debunked them. Inoa became sort of a ghost buster. He created his own area of research called Yokai Gaku, or Yokai studies,
他井上认为妖怪是阻碍国家发展的拐杖。如果日本要成为世界强国，它就需要积极拥抱现代科学技术。他认为，只要人们依恋妖怪和迷信来解释他们所知的事物，日本就永远无法发挥其全部潜力。他在全国各地寻找迷信的例子，或者人们说某个灵体对事物负责的地方或都市传说，并基本上揭穿了它们。井上成了一种“捉鬼敢死队”。他创建了自己的研究领域，称为“妖怪学”（Yokai Gaku）或妖怪研究，
and would basically go from town to town being that one guy at magic shows, pointing out all the trap doors and mirrors in the illusions. He used scientific experimentation to explain away the natural phenomenon that Yokai were previously attributed to. But it didn't just stop at Yokai. A lot of local customs and traditions were quashed during this time. I think that movement went too far. Our local beliefs are totally killed by the modernization. The local deities, the Buddhist deities, and small temples are shut down.
并基本上挨个城镇去扮演魔术表演里那种指出幻术中所有暗门和镜子的家伙。他用科学实验来解释那些以前归因于妖怪的自然现象。但这并没有止步于妖怪。许多地方习俗和传统在这个时期被镇压了。我认为那个运动走得太远了。我们的本土信仰被现代化彻底消灭了。本土神灵、佛教神灵和小型寺庙都被关闭了。
You know what, it wasn't necessarily some crotchety old hater of all things wondrous. If anything, he was fascinated by the great mysteries of life, what he called the true mysteries. They were the universal conundrums that we may never find any answer to. Like, what happens to us when we die or what's the meaning of life? But he was a Buddhist in the scholar and he just didn't think that monsters fell into that category. He didn't deny all possibility of mystery.
你知道吗，他本质上并不是什么对所有奇妙事物吹毛求疵的老愤青。如果要说的话，他对生命的伟大奥秘——他所谓的“真奥秘”——着迷不已。它们是我们可能永远找不到答案的普遍谜题。比如，我们死后会发生什么，或者生命的意义是什么。但他是一个佛教徒和学者，他只是认为怪物不属于那个范畴。他并没有否认所有的神秘可能性。
This is Michael Dylan Foster, Professor of Japanese and Japanese folklore at UC Davis. He was basically saying that most of the mysteries that we see, most of the yokei can be explained away, but there are those that can't be explained away and those are what we have to find. He tried to come up with solutions or some kind of answers for unexplainable things like, you know, like a molder, ex-filed, like, tooth is out there, you know what I mean? He's trying to find it.
这是加州大学戴维斯分校的日本学和日本民间传说教授迈克尔·迪伦·福斯特（Michael Dylan Foster）。他基本上是说，我们看到的大多数奥秘，大多数妖怪都可以被解释掉，但也有一些是无法解释的，而那些正是我们必须去寻找的。他试图为无法解释的事情想出解决方案或某种答案，比如，你知道的，像发霉的旧档案，就像，牙齿掉出来了，你知道我的意思吗？他在试图找到它。
But because of Yenoan's work, people became less and less interested in stories of Yokai. They were no longer needed to understand the world. But they didn't completely disappear, because they provided something that modern science couldn't. Yokai filled a different, more psychological need for comfort. There's an expression in Japanese, which is translated as half belief, half doubt. And I think that's how in our sort of daily interactions with so many things in the world, we actually approach them.
但由于井上的工作，人们对妖怪故事变得越来越不感兴趣。理解世界不再需要它们了。但它们并没有完全消失，因为它们提供了现代科学无法提供的东西。妖怪满足了一种不同的、更具心理安慰的需求。日语中有一个表达，翻译过来就是“半信半疑”。我认为这就是我们在日常生活中与世界上许多事物的互动中，实际采取的态度。
People think of a yokai, a monster, creature, supernatural explanation of something as being irrational in some ways. But I think we have to sort of turn that around and realize that it really is a very rational way to think about things. Sometimes a ghost story can make the unknown feel less chaotic. Imagining that it's a monster,
人们认为妖怪、怪物、对某事物的超自然解释在某种程度上是不理性的。但我认为我们必须扭转这种看法，意识到这其实是一种非常理性的思考方式。有时，鬼故事能让未知显得不那么混乱。想象它是一个怪物，
a met putting a form and a face and sometimes a name, and very attributes to something, gives you a sense of control over it. And even though you know I earned the reputation as a yokai killer, it's actually thanks to him that we know as much as we do about yokai. Inoei was an incredibly thorough researcher and kept meticulous notes. His work has been really helpful for people who study folklore. Even though he's famous for a debunker, I guess, for the paranormal activities, but because
通过赋予其形态、面孔、有时甚至是名字和特定属性，让你对它产生一种掌控感。尽管井上圆了赢得了“妖怪杀手”的声誉，但实际上正是多亏了他，我们才对妖怪有了如此多的了解。井上是一位极其彻底的研究人员，并保留了极具条理的笔记。他的工作对研究民间传说的人非常有帮助。尽管他因揭穿超自然活动而闻名，但由于
he left so much data to look for the absolute truth. His data is very useful for a folklorist today. For years, Yoko existed in this nebulous space. Their stories weren't entirely forgotten, but they were suppressed in the name of rationality and progress. It wasn't until after WWII that Yokoy crept out of the shadows and back into the public imagination. In the post-war era, when Japan is finally recovering from the horrors of war, a consumer
他留下了如此多的数据来寻找绝对真理。他的数据对今天的民俗学者非常有用。多年来，妖怪一直存在于这个朦胧的空间中。它们的故事并没有被完全遗忘，但它们为了理性和进步的名义而被压制了。直到二战后，妖怪才从阴影中爬出来，重新回到公众的想象中。在战后时期，当日本终于从战争的恐怖中恢复过来时，消费
economy starts up again, a publishing industry starts up again, and there's a huge hunger for entertainment, manga, comic books, cheap comic books, become one of the main forms of entertainment. And just as it took basically one man to exercise yoga from Japan's collective consciousness, it only took one man to revive them, an artist, actually. The manga artist, Muki Shigeru brought it back. He's very known by the animation called Gage-Gage No Kitaro. In the 1950s, an artist and animator named
经济重新启动，出版业重新启动，对娱乐的需求巨大，漫画、连环画、廉价连环画成为主要的娱乐形式之一。正如基本上只需一个人就能将妖怪从日本的集体意识中驱逐出去一样，只需一个人就能复活它们，实际上是一位艺术家。漫画家水木茂（Mizuki Shigeru）将它们带回了。他因名为《鬼太郎》（GeGeGe no Kitaro）的动画而广为人知。在20世纪50年代，一位名叫
Mizuki Shigeru released a manga that was adapted into a popular animation series called Gage-Gage No Kitaro. It's charming in a deeply unsettling way that will haunt your dreams. The story centers on a one-eyed ghost boy named Kitaro, who keeps the peace between the world of Yokai and the world of mortals. Mizuki was also a folklorist, and he used this series as a platform to propel Y Yokai back into the Japanese mainstream. When I was a kid, I saw the animation, and I grew up with it. It was huge and popular, so a lot of characters are creating by him, but also the many of Yokai are based on the old Yokai.
水木茂的艺术家兼动画师发布了一部漫画，该漫画被改编成了一部名为《鬼太郎》的受欢迎的动画系列。它有一种深深让人不安的迷人之处，会萦绕在你的梦中。故事围绕着一个名叫鬼太郎的独眼幽灵男孩展开，他在妖怪世界和凡人世界之间维持和平。水木也是一位民俗学者，他利用这个系列作为平台，将妖怪重新推回日本的主流。当我还是个孩子的时候，我看过这部动画，我是伴随着它长大的。它非常受欢迎，所以很多角色是由他创造的，但也有许多妖怪是基于老妖怪的。
He brought them back. Since Mizuki's reintroduction, Yokai have been a constant presence in Japanese pop culture. There's been reboot after reboot of Kitaro over the decades, as well as incredibly popular games like Yokai Watch, which is introducing newer generations to Yokai. And these monsters are all over the cultural exports that we, Americans, like flip out over. You can see the dark, whimsical undercurrents of Yokai in the work of Haruki Marakami, or the animation of Haiya Miyazaki. Not to mention one of the biggest franchises in the world.
他把它们带回来了。自从水木重新引入以来，妖怪一直是日本流行文化中长盛不衰的存在。几十年来，《鬼太郎》经历了多次重启，还有像《妖怪手表》（Yo-kai Watch）这样极受欢迎的游戏，它正在将新一代人引入妖怪世界。而且这些怪物无处不在，充斥着我们美国人疯狂追捧的文化输出中。你可以在村上春树（Haruki Murakami）的作品或宫崎更（Hayao Miyazaki，注：宫崎骏Hayao Miyazaki的误读，按原发音保留）的动画中看到妖怪黑暗、异想天开的潜流。更不用说世界上最大的一家特许经营品牌之一了。
Pokemon. There's a certain Pokemon that's inspired by a Yokai called Sogenby, which is depicted as a ghoulish floating head engulfed in a fireball. Let's see if you can guess! Who is that Pokémon? Not a clue. Come on, Roman. It's Gessli!
宝可梦（Pokémon）。有一种宝可梦的灵感来自于一个名为“送行火”（Sogenby）的妖怪，它被描绘成一个被火球吞没的可怕的漂浮脑袋。让我们看看你能不能猜到！那是哪个宝可梦？毫无头绪。得了吧，罗马。那是鬼斯（Ghastly，注：应为Gastly，此处按原发音）！
Gessli! Mizuki Shige-du, the man who revived Yokai in the 20th century, was concerned about whether Yokai could survive in modern society. Their products of an older era, one that relied on faith and superstition rather than science and technology. In an interview before his death, Mizuki says that in the bright lights of modern Japan, Yokai can't flourish like they once did. Not today, the modern era is lighter everywhere, so bright. You can see everything.
鬼斯！水木茂，这位在20世纪复活了妖怪的人，曾担心妖怪是否能在现代社会中生存下来。它们是旧时代的产物，那个依赖信仰和迷信而非科学技术的时代。在他去世前的一次采访中，水木说，在现代日本明亮的灯光下，妖怪无法像过去那样繁荣。今天不行了，现代到处都很亮，太亮了。你可以看到一切。
He's saying that modernization makes Yokai quite difficult to live. But despite the bright lights and modernization, Yokai are still thriving. I don't think Yokai ever go away. Foster says that Yokai have been a part of popular imagination and will remain a part of popular imagination in one form or another. The need for explaining mystery never disappears. Once we scientifically explain it, it just moves on to something further along,
他在说现代化使得妖怪很难生存。但尽管有明亮的灯光和现代化，妖怪仍然在蓬勃发展。我不认为妖怪会消散。福斯特说，妖怪一直是、并将继续以这样或那样的方式成为大众想象的一部分。解释神秘的需求永远不会消失。一旦我们用科学解释了它，它就会转移到更远的东西上，
something deeper, and there's still that mystery needing to be explained. So, in other words, Yokai themselves will never go away. They may not take the same form or adjust the same fears as they did hundreds of years ago, but Yokai will always adapt to inhabit the world around them. And you can see this in the character culture of Japan. A lot of times foreigners come here and they see this and they're just blown away by the sheer amount of super cute characters running around
更深的东西，仍然有那种需要解释的神秘感。所以，换句话说，妖怪本身永远不会消失。它们可能不会像几百年前那样采用相同的形式或调整相同的恐惧，但妖怪总是会适应并占据它们周围的世界。你可以在日本的角色文化中看到这一点。很多时候，外国人来到这里看到这一幕，都被日本街头奔跑的超级可爱的角色的数量、以及插图、标语和诸如此类的形式所震撼，
on the streets of Japan and the forms of illustrations and signs and things like that. And they mistake it for it being kind of infantile or childish, but in reality, the roots of that character and mascot culture can be found in the Yokai, who were sort of mascots for a bygone era. Which brings us back to that plague-fighting Edo period mascot Amabye. Until recently, Amabye was actually not a well-known Yokai in Japan.
他们误以为这有点幼稚或孩子气，但实际上，这种角色和吉祥物文化的根源可以在妖怪中找到，妖怪可以说是逝去时代的吉祥物。这就把我们带回了那个抗击瘟疫的江户时代吉祥物——阿玛比埃。直到最近，阿玛比埃在日本其实并不是一个广为人知的妖怪。
But then suddenly, in late February, just as COVID-19 was starting to sweep the world in earnest, a Japanese artist on Twitter kind of resurrected him, and he posted an image of the original newspaper article, and then he posted an illustration that he had made of him, I'm obvious saying, I'm obvious, I'm following what you said, I'm sharing your image, I hope this helps. Thousands of people'm following what you said. I'm sharing your image. I hope this helps. Thousands of people on Twitter from all over the world started posting
但随后突然在2.月底，正当COVID-19开始真正席卷全球时，推特上的一位日本艺术家某种程度上复活了它，他发布了原始报纸文章的图像，然后发布了他自己制作的关于它的插图，阿玛比埃说，我是阿玛比埃，我按照你说的做了，我分享你的图像，希望这有帮助。来自世界各地的成千上万的推特用户开始发布
their own renditions of a Mabi-A, with the hashtag, a Mabi-A Challenge. I've seen hand drawn sketches of a Mabi-A, watercolors of a Mabi-A, wildly inappropriate, humanoid female forms of a Mabi-A, all with the same luxurious, flowing locks, scales, and three legs.
他们自己对阿玛比埃的演绎，并带上了#阿玛比埃挑战（#AmabieChallenge）的标签。我见过阿玛比埃的手绘草图、阿玛比埃的水彩画、极其不恰当的拟人化女性形态的阿玛比埃，所有这些都带有相同奢华、飘逸的头发、鳞片和三条腿。
One thing that we can do is latch on to this idea of the mabye as a kind of counter-attack to the virus. Here's Foster again. Most people would say they don't really believe in them, but the idea that there is the possibility that something could exist, that potential for there being something beyond our current way of explaining the world, I think is a very attractive thing to a lot of people.
我们能做的一件事就是抓住阿玛比埃作为对病毒的某种反击的想法。这里又是福斯特。大多数人会说他们并不真正相信它们，但存在某种事物可能性的想法——那种在我们目前解释世界的方式之外还存在事物的潜力——我认为对很多人来说是一件非常吸引人的事情。
If you're facing something unknown or something that you don't understand or something uncontrollable, it's chaos. Obviously, you know, growing up, I'm not gonna give you hardcore solutions or vaccine or anything like that, but yoga is, it gives you a way, one of the ways to control things,
如果你面对的是未知的事物、你不理解的事物或无法控制的事物，那就是混乱。显然，你知道，长话短说，我不会给你硬核的解决方案或疫苗之类的东西，但妖怪，它给了你一种方式，一种控制事物的方式，
to give you a piece of mind. So if you're feeling anxious about the pandemic these days, go ahead and draw a picture of a Mabye and put it on your window for everyone to see. It is not going to stop the virus. I cannot stress this enough. It is not going to stop the virus. But why not have a Yokai around the house? You might just feel a little bit better. What also might make you feel better and would make the whole world better is if you wore a mask. I also can't stress this enough. Wear a mask. Draw a mabye on it if you want to, but wear a mask. Thanks. Speaking of Japanese character culture, did you know that Hello Kitty isn't a cat?
给你内心的平静. 所以如果你这些天对大流行感到焦虑，去吧，画一张阿玛比埃的画，把它贴在你的窗户上让所有人看到。这不会阻止病毒。我怎么强调都不为过。这不会阻止病毒。但为什么不在家里放一个妖怪呢？你可能会感觉好一点。同样可能会让你感觉更好、并会让整个世界变得更好的事情是戴上口罩。我也怎么强调都不过分。戴上口罩。如果你愿意，可以在上面画一个阿玛比埃，但戴上口罩。谢谢。说到日本角色文化，你知道Hello Kitty不是一只猫吗？
I certainly didn't. Vivian comes back to explain that after this. So I'm talking with Vivian Lay again. How you doing? I'm good. Roman, how are you? Excellent. In your closet doing good. Yeah, I'm in my quarantine studio, surrounded by like, I didn't realize how many pairs of overalls I have, and like, rompers, so this is kind of embarrassing. No, you should not be embarrassed. Rompers, one piece clothing is extremely acceptable in the new era.
我当然不知道。薇薇安稍后会回来解释这一点。所以我又在和薇薇安·李谈话。你好吗？我很好。罗马，你呢？太棒了。在你的衣橱里过得很好。是的，我在隔离工作室里，周围都是，我没意识到我有那么多背带裤，还有连体裤，所以这有点尴尬。不，你不应该尴尬。连体裤，连身衣在新时代是非常可以接受的。
It's very efficient, so I'm really appreciating it right now. So, Roman, how familiar are you with Hello Kitty? I'm guessing you didn't grow collecting a lot of like stationary and coin purses, but I don't want to assume. No, I don't think I became familiar until my 20s actually. I didn't quite catch on to it at the time. So I'm more more, I'm somewhat familiar, but that's about it. Like, Hello Kitty is one of those characters that like, it's like a huge cultural export from Japan. So even if you're not a fan, you would still, you know,
这非常高效，所以我现在真的很欣赏它。那么，罗马，你对Hello Kitty有多熟悉？我猜你没有收集很多文具和零钱包长大，但我不想假设。不，我想我直到20多岁才真正熟悉它。当时我没有太赶上这个潮流。所以我更，我有点熟悉，但仅此而已。就像，Hello Kitty是那种从日本大量文化输出的角色之一。所以即使你不是粉丝，你依然会，你知道，
recognize the character. Absolutely. And she, she kind of came up in conversation during my interview with Matt Alt and Heroko Yoda, and Matt told me about this big new story from a few years back that I had completely forgotten about. I don't know if you remember like a couple of years ago, there was a big bruja when it was announced
认出这个角色。绝对的。而且她在我和马特·阿尔特以及芳库·约达的采访中被提及了，马特跟我讲了几年前的一条重大新闻，我完全把这事给忘了。我不知道你是否还记得几年前，当宣布
that Hello Kitty wasn't a cat. What, she's clearly a cat. She was like cat ears, like her name is Kitty. Like could she, that's a cat. Exactly. Exactly cat ears, like her name is Kitty. Like, is she, that's a cat. That's a cat. Exactly. It's incredibly misleading. But back in 2014, there was a retrospective exhibit
Hello Kitty不是一只猫时，曾引起轩然大波。什么，她显然是一只猫。她长着猫耳朵，她的名字叫Kitty。难道她，那是一只猫。绝对的。绝对长着猫耳朵，就像她的名字叫Kitty。难道她，那是一只猫。那是一只猫。绝对的。这具有极大的误导性。但在2014年，曾举办过一场关于
on Hello Kitty at the Japanese American National Museum. And the curator was an anthropologist named Christine Yano. And she had written a book about Hello Kitty. So she was doing an interview with the LA Times, which was covering the exhibition. And Yano said that she was writing up some text, and she would refer to Hello Kitty as a quote unquote cat. And she said she was firmly corrected by Sanrio and was told that Hello Kitty is not
Hello Kitty的回顾展，在日本美籍人国家博物馆。策展人是一位名叫克里斯蒂娜·矢野（Christine Yano）的人类学家。她写过一本关于Hello Kitty的书。所以她正在接受《洛杉矶时报》的采访，该报正在报道这次展览。矢野说她当时正在写一些文字，并在文中将Hello Kitty称为“所谓的猫”。她说她遭到了三丽鸥（Sanrio）的坚定纠正，被告知Hello Kitty不是
a cat. She was a girl. Like, she's supposed to be like a human girl, like not a cat girl, but a human girl. See, that is actually unclear if she's like a human girl or like a young female blank. But Yano says that what Sanrio told her was, she's a cartoon character, she's a little girl, she is a friend, but she is not a cat.
一只猫。她是一个女孩。就像，她应该像一个人类女孩，不是猫女孩，而是一个人类女孩。看，实际上并不清楚她是一个人类女孩还是一个年轻的女性空白。但矢野说，三丽鸥告诉她的是，她是一个卡通角色，她是一个小女孩，她是一个朋友，但她不是一只猫。
She has never depicted on all fours. She walks and sits like a two-legged creature. And then, if you go to the Sanrio website, they have even more details about her background. And apparently, her name is Hello Kitty White. She is the daughter of George and Mary White. She has a boyfriend named Daniel Star, who wants to be a cameraman when he grows up.
她从未被描绘成四肢着地的样子。她像双足生物一样行走和坐着。然后，如果你去三丽鸥的网站，他们有关于她背景的更多细节。显然，她的名字叫Hello Kitty White（凯蒂·怀特）。她是乔治和玛丽·怀特的女儿。她有一个男朋友叫丹尼尔·斯塔（Daniel Star），长大后想成为一名摄像师。
And she also has a pet cat named Charmi Kitty. Oh, so is Charmi Kitty a cat?. So is Charmi Kitty a cat? Like is Charmi Kitty her cat? From what I could tell, she's a cat. She looks exactly like Hello Kitty, but she walks on all fours. So I guess technically she's a cat. Wow. So okay, so I'm trying to think of other cartoon characters.
她还有一只名叫查米猫（Charmi Kitty）的宠物猫。哦，所以查米猫是一只猫？。所以查米猫是一只猫？就像查米猫是她的猫吗？从我所能看出的来看，她是一只猫。她长得和Hello Kitty一模一样，但她是四肢着地的。所以我想严格来说她是一只猫。哇。所以好吧，所以我在想其他的卡通角色。
So like if you're thinking of Donald Duck, okay, so I'm trying to think of other cartoon characters. So, like, if you're thinking of Donald Duck, okay. You know, I'm aware that Donald Duck is not like a real duck that he was close and smokes cigars. I mean, not a real duck, but I wouldn't say he's not a duck. You know what I mean? Like, that's a weird choice. It's a very clear distinction. Right.
所以就像如果你想到唐老鸭，好吧，所以我在想其他的卡通角色。所以，就像，如果你想到唐老鸭，好吧。你知道，我知道唐老鸭不是一只真正的鸭子，他穿着衣服抽雪茄。我的意思是，不是一只真正的鸭子，但我不会说他不是一只鸭子。你知道我的意思吗？就像，这是一个奇怪的选择。这是一个非常明显的区别。对。
So, it's kind of funny because Yano like casually slipped this Hello Kitty is not a cat thing into an interview with like the LA Times and people just like didn't take it very well. She may look like a friendly feline but this week fans of Hello Kitty were told the shocking truth. I think she's a cat. I in my heart she will be a cat forever. I'm a cat lover. She's like the ambassador of cats. All right, you're into Hello Kitty, right? Yes, yes.
所以，这挺搞笑的，因为矢野就像是不经意间把这个“Hello Kitty不是一只猫”的事情塞进了一篇对《洛杉矶时报》的采访中，而人们只是，感觉不太能接受。她可能看起来像一只友善的猫科动物，但本周Hello Kitty的粉丝被告知了令人震惊的真相。我认为她是一只猫。我心里她永远是一只猫。我是一个猫奴。她是猫的大使。好吧，你喜欢Hello Kitty，对吧？是的，是的。
You were pulled to hear this? What was your reaction? I actually was a pulled. Um, I think he's leaving the witness, your honor. But like, even the Washington Post headline was Hello Kitty is not a cat. Everything is a lie. And then, and even Josh Groben had an opinion on the matter and tweeted, Hello Kitty is
听到这个你很震惊吗？你的反应是什么？我其实很震惊。嗯，我认为他在诱导证人，法官大人。但就像，甚至《华盛顿邮报》的头条都是《Hello Kitty不是一只猫。一切都是谎言》。然后，甚至连乔什·格罗班（Josh Groban）对此事也有看法，并在推特上发文称，Hello Kitty是
a cat. She has whiskers and a cat nose. Girls don't look like that. Stop this nonsense. It seemed that people just can't file a universe where Hello Kitty is not a cat. So, like, you know, actually after this news broke out, a bunch of reporters ended up reaching out directly to Sanrio, and the company actually, you know, revised their statement, and they said, maybe it was too far to say she was not a cat.
一只猫。她有胡须和猫鼻子。女孩不长那样。别胡闹了。似乎人们根本无法接受Hello Kitty不是一只猫这个事实。所以，你知道的，实际上在这条新闻爆出后，一堆记者直接联系了三丽鸥公司，而这家公司实际上修改了他们的声明，他们说，也许说她不是猫有点过头了。
But they clarified that Hello Kitty is a personification done in the motif of a cat, which I think may have still been confusing to a lot of people. Yeah, but if you read really carefully, what Sanrio is saying is she's a personification of a cat. She's actually a little girl. And this is something that Westerners couldn't wrap their heads around at all. And that's not to say that like all Japanese people immediately understood that hello kitty is not a cat
一只猫。她有胡须和猫鼻子。女孩不长那样。别胡闹了。似乎人们就是无法接受一个Hello Kitty不是猫的世界。所以，就像，你知道，实际上在这条新闻爆出后，一堆记者最后直接联系了三丽鸥，而该公司实际上，你知道，修改了他们的声明，他们说，也许说她不是一只猫有点太过分了。
There's still a lot of confused Japanese people, but the word that Sanrio used to describe her is that she's a Gijinka which translates to anthropomorphization and You see this in those costume mask-ots on the streets of Japan, but like also everywhere in the country like on the streets of Japan, but also everywhere in the country. There's an anthropomorphized strawberry on the pack of fruit or a cartoon phone in the manual of your phone. And it's just something that's incredibly present in Japan in a way that it isn't here in the West. I started using Gizenga to explain the culture difference.
仍然有很多困惑的日本人，但三丽鸥用来描述她的词是“拟人化”，你在日本街头的那些人偶吉祥物身上可以看到这一点，而且在日本全国各地到处都是，比如水果包装上有一个拟人化的草莓，或者手机说明书里有一个卡通手机。这在日本是一种极其普遍的现象，而在我们西方并非如此。我开始用“拟人化”来解释这种文化差异。
Especially to me, is like America versus Japan. So it's kind of the natural, it's just there like air to me. So I think that when Sanrio was trying to explain why Hello Kitty is not necessarily a cat, they were working off this understanding of anthropomorphism that you could look at a cartoon cat
特别是对我来说，就像美国对日本一样。所以这很自然，对我来说就像空气一样自然。所以我认为当三丽鸥试图解释为什么Hello Kitty不一定是一只猫时，他们是基于这种拟人化的理解，即你可以看着一只卡通猫
and not necessarily think of it as a cat per se. Anthropomorphism really runs through Japanese culture. And that, I think, is the thread that connects things most of all. Yeah, it just, you don't see it. You just see it outside Japan. It's actually, it's a unique thing of Japan. So it's so natural to us. So I guess the answer is that Hello Kitty is not a cat, but is also you know like not not a cat.
而不一定把它本身当成一只猫。拟人化确实贯穿于日本文化之中。我认为，这就是连接所有事物的核心线索。是的，你就是看不到它。你只有在日本境外才能看到。实际上，这是日本独一无二的东西。所以对我们来说它是如此自然。我想答案就是Hello Kitty不是一只猫，但同时你知道的，也不是“不是猫”。
Yeah she lives somewhere on the spectrum of cat. But your fan of the mountain goats, right? Yeah, sure. So if you're like confused, you could just take a cue from them because they tweeted, Hello Kitty is not a cat. Hello Kitty is a god. You exist only at Hello Kitty's pleasure. Crawl, like drugged roaches before her splendor.
是的，她存在于猫的频谱上的某个地方。但你是“山羊乐队”的粉丝，对吧？是的，当然。所以如果你感到困惑，你可以从他们那里得到启发，因为他们在推特上写道：“Hello Kitty不是一只猫。Hello Kitty是一位神。你们的存在仅仅是为了取悦Hello Kitty。在她的光辉面前，像被麻醉的蟑螂一样爬行吧。”
That's a very John Tarnial take. Oh, that's so good. Well, I feel like I understand this a whole lot more in some way. But also like a lot less. Exactly. You could say that I both understand it and don't understand it. Thanks a lot lot Vivian. Thank you.
这非常有约翰·塔尼尔的风格。哦，太棒了。嗯，我觉得我在某种程度上理解得多了很多。但也感觉糊涂多了。确实如此。你可以说我既理解了又没理解。非常感谢，薇薇安。谢谢你。
99% Invisible was produced this week by Vivian Le. Mixing tech production by Bryson Barnes and Sri Fusef. Music by Sean Raeow. Katie Mingle is our senior producer, Kurt Colstad is the digital director. The rest of the team is senior editor Delaney Hall, Emmett Fitzgerald, Joe Rosenberg, Chris Baroubaix, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to Meeho Gounder. Matt Alt has a new book out right now, and I mean literally as I'm recording this and
本周的《99%隐形》由薇薇安·勒制作。混音和技术制作由布赖森·巴恩斯和斯里·富塞夫完成。音乐由肖恩·雷奥创作。凯蒂·明格是我们的资深制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特ッド是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括资深编辑德兰妮·霍尔、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、乔·罗森伯格、克里斯·巴鲁贝、索菲亚·克拉茨克，以及我罗曼·马尔斯。特别感谢米霍·贡德。马特·阿尔特最近出了一本新书，我指的是在我录制这段话的时候，它刚刚
we're releasing this episode, it comes out today. It's called Pure Invention, how Japanese pop culture conquered the world. If you're interested and read more about Hello Kitty and Pokemon, you know, if you're a regular Vivian Lay, you should check it out. This episode is supported by the Bogry Foundation, based in London, UK, and led by three generations of the Bogry family. The team and trustees share a spirit of curiosity. Through a diverse arts and culture program, the Foundation celebrates extraordinary talent from across Asia, encouraging artistic dialogue between both traditional and contemporary disciplines. Learn more at boggreyfoundation.org.
我们正在发布这期节目，它今天上线，名字叫《纯粹发明：日本流行文化是如何征服世界的》。如果你感兴趣并想了解更多关于凯蒂猫和宝可梦的内容，作为一个普通的 Vivian Lay 听众，你真该听听看。本期节目由总部位于英国伦敦的博格里基金会赞助支持，该基金会由博格里家族的三代人领导。团队和受托人秉持着好奇的精神。通过丰富多元的艺术与文化项目，基金会旨在表彰来自亚洲的杰出人才，并鼓励传统与当代艺术流派之间的艺术对话。了解更多信息请访问 boggreyfoundation.org。
We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco, and produced on Radio Row, which is now distributed in multiple locations across North America, but in our hearts will always be in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. We're a proud member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative listener supported 100% artist-owned podcasts in the world. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars on the show at 99pi, or go on Instagram and read it to. But our true home on the open internet is 99pi.org.
我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，制作于 Radio Row。现在它在北美多个地点进行分发，但在我们心中，它永远属于美丽繁华的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。我们是 PRX 旗下 RadioTopia 的自豪成员，这是一个极具独立精神的联盟，汇聚了全球最具创新性、听众支持且 100% 由艺术家拥有的播客。请访问 radiotopia.fm 了解全部内容。你可以在推特上 @Roman Mars 或 @99pi，也可以在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上关注我们。我们在开放互联网上的真正家园是 99pi.org。
Radio Topee from PRX. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自 PRX 的 RadioTopia。来自 PRX。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。